[Musique]
mais voilà alors merci bonjour merci
merci d'être là merci crise hier être là
vous êtes artiste animalistes et
présidente de la société de
l'association à casa c'est ça quand vous
êtes pour l'interdiction de la corrida
et merci à yanis yanis et ziadi comédien
est passionné de corrida merci yanis et
merci et crise hier
alors pour ou contre la corrida donc là
surtout faut-il interdire la corrida
série qu'on en parle de plus en plus de
cette interdiction de la corrida parce
que c'est vrai qu'on ya beaucoup de gens
ils disent avec les spectacles qu'ils
reprennent lé corrida qui reprennent et
vous vous dites vous dit non non moi je
suis pour la laquelle la corrida mais
moi j'ai découvert la corrida très
récemment je suis pas du tout un
aficionado là de la première heure j'ai
découvert ça il ya un an
en lisant des livres je me suis dit
c'est pas possible qu autant de grands
écrivains s'intéresse à cet art je suis
allé dans les arènes j'ai vu le
contraire de ce que j'avais entendu
c'est à dire j'ai couru la conte le
contraire de la torture d'un animal et
en plus d'aller voir les corridas je
suis allé visiter les élevages
rencontrer les éleveurs les toreros et
j'ai découvert un milieu qui était le
contraire de ce que de ce qu'on m'avait
raconté
bah oui c'est sûr que dans les élevages
que vous avez dû aller visiter donc les
animaux sont bien traités le temps de
leur vie sont massés c'est la thalasso
et après ils sont taillés en pièces dans
les arènes à nîmes ou à alès dans les
pays
enfin dans le sud de la france alors non
benjamin castaldi aussi pasqua écouté
moi je n'aime pas la corrida il ya très
longtemps sur canal+ qui était la
première chaîne à diffuser et c'est vrai
que je rejoins monsieur c'est vrai que
c'est un spectacle incroyable c'est vrai
que c'est un combat entre l'homme et
l'animal c'est vrai que pour le coup les
animaux tout leur toutou lelong douleur
et ne valent ils sont très bien traités
alors c'est vrai qu'elle est mise à mort
qui effectivement est un moment
compliqué je suis d'accord avec vous
mais je trouve que l'affrontement de
l'animal et de l'homme dans ce cas
précis voilà je suis je du jeu voilà je
pense qu'il faut pas interdite aux
médias pour plein dedans si ces modes
vous le dire mais pourra y avoir d'un
franchement est un combat loyal
déjà c'est un contre un bah c'est pas le
cas il ya toute une escadrille qui est
autour du taureau oui les mandrills et
mais bon deux personnes qui sont
d'accord ils ont signé pour faire un
combat là vous êtes ont dit ne pas faire
d'anthropomorphisme dans la cause
animale
on nous dit pas comparer les animaux les
humains et là en l'occurrence on en fait
notre part marc chisson dire ah bah
c'est un combattant comme un autre qui
est contre
un autre type cas d épée mais moi j'ai
envie de vous dire si il aime les épais
si l'ism les pyjamas fluo satisfasse de
l'escrimé qui adore les animaux dans des
mosquées bondées un spectacle -
effectivement me fascine et
l'affrontement de l'animal et de cette
bête qui était pour le coût élevé je
pense de façon extrêmement correct et
courtois
je dérange pas voilà gilles verdez c'est
pas un spectacle c'est une mise à mort
voilà bizarrement aujourd'hui ici sur ce
plateau tout le monde tout le temps
milite pour les droits des animaux est
non alors la corrida on accède benjamin
parce que c'est une tradition locale
ininterrompue dans 65 villes on peut
mettre à mort des animaux
c'est honteux c'est un scandale alors
aujourd'hui à vous avez vu que la mise à
mort est interdite depuis 1928 gérald
boutin membres non parce qu'en fait
j'entends vos arguments et j'ai trouvé
absolument recevable et chaud comprend
que sa sculpture etc tacle absolument
cruel et dérangeant mais malgré tout il
ya quelque chose
moi je trouve dans la tradition dans la
dans la coutume c'est vrai que l'air du
temps c'est de considérer que la nuit
l'animal est l'égal de l'homme et moi je
ne pense pas je pense que l'homme est au
dessus de l'animal je comprends que ça
puisse choquer ça me dérange pas par
exemple quand on fait des cantons test
ou quads et des médicaments sur les
souris ou sur les rats ça ne me choque
pas moi en tant que humaine donc voilà
je comprends que ça vous choque même
alors tous là c'est en espagne au
portugal ou dans le silence je vois que
je vous ai clairement si on prenait le
même tour aux on le mettait dans une
arène à paris les personnes qui
organisent deux ans de prison 30 mille
euros damende ça c'est l'article 521 1
du code pénal
accor s'est interdit partout comprend le
même animal il n'a pas les îles il est
bon il a plus aucun droit ont-ils et
dans le sud vous parlez d'un spectacle
c'est une et vous parlez d'une mise à
mort mais la mise à mort elle commence à
partir du moment où le taureau entre
dans l'arène
il est dans un dans un élevage où il est
bien traité on le mas on le rombo
brillant vraiment le prépare comme une
voiture de course pour qu'ils se fassent
des montées dans les arènes et dans les
alzonnais variante c'est pas la même
chose et justifiant qu'ils sont on est
en effet m d'habitude j'ai aujourd'hui
la nourriture si vous allez par la rdo
juppé avec la nourriture ne vois pas
pourquoi ils ont fait ça excusez moi
parler aux toreros par les autorités ils
sont pas là pour rien et que reinhardt
et aux aficionados
et puis si on allait en parler aux
aficionados et la dette publics
excusez-moi par les hausses des
aficionados qui sont là dans le public
ils sont pas là pour s'amuser ils vivent
à mon nom sacré alors à chacun de mes
frères nous allions que vous ne puissiez
pas longtemps dans nos journaux mais je
comprends que le 5 raisons crise il m'a
donné des français ne le coupent et bien
a ajouté je suis en général je demande
la parole pour parler éviter de me
couper s'il vous plaît oui je voudrais
dire une chose que je de jeu je trouve
importantes c'est très difficile de
faire un débat pour ou contre la corrida
de toute façon c'est un dialogue de
sourds madame dire à ces arguments et je
dirais les miens moi ce que je veux dire
c'est que il ya une chose importante à
dire c'est que à la corrida
le public ne vient pas pour voir pour
jouir de la souffrance d'un animal
pourquoi on avait pourquoi parce que on
ne voit pas un animal souffrir leur art
auront rien mais attendez la castellane
terminé mois terminés monde et on les
connaît en plus aux arguments les entend
toute la journée
non non c'est messi on entend ça et là
je dis juste une chose se colle au
taureau montre ce n'est pas de la
souffrance
un peu vous même vous êtes des cartes
mais mais mais attendez on voit pas un
taureau partir quand il se fait piquer
ton char tir et cours quoi ne peut pas
taper leurs excuses et complètement
barré
avec abc votre eau chauffée des leçons
sur les tons page et le garder qu'est ce
que vous lui avez deux minutes 2010 est
sacrée mais sa tranquille j'en ai pas ok
tu te mettais barjots de dire c'est
sacré la corrida et des savanes
c'est un art mais été coupé par ces
contenants maladie ça vous légitimez le
massacre d'un taureau dans l'arène
nationale 21 on n'est plus au temps
romain d'accord à l'antiquité où il y
avait les combats de cirque de 2,2 dans
les arènes s'est terminée sans lui en
2021 en occident je me pose la question
de l'arrêt s'est passé quelque chose
mais moi j'ai non mais il a raison il a
raison je plussoie tout à fait c'est
scandaleux en fait mon que cette
personne nous disent que c'est de la
nasa censée rendre les choses beaucoup
de belles choses que vous écrivez alors
garde des sceaux c'est une des choses
malbaie les cinq ans être coûté une
seconde secteur alors à ce moment-là
vous l'aimez pris des couleurs douces et
des bd sort de bourrins des assassins
des clés mais là les choses évoluent
aujourd'hui on a reconnu la sensibilité
à leur animal comment ça se fait que cet
article 521-1 ne s'applique pas dans le
sud
il s'implique à paris serait drôlement
s'agirait donc il faut changer c'est
loin alors est-ce que ça c'est clair
qu'on n'a pas entendu quelqu'un arriver
la fleur de peau elle est aussi un
dommage et vous aimez corrida est un
petit pas mais tu vas nous faire
pardonnez moi parce que l'homme et c'est
pourquoi il est là le cheval le touriste
est pas mauvais il est là en plus on l'a
vu avec les picadors seul affaibli avec
les trucs et eu ces mots que vous avez
senti l'odeur du sang séché dans une
arène
mais je suis à l'étalagé pas mais oui
mais c'est à mon sens six mois à la
douche à moi j'ai deux chats je les
caresse et au mal et on remet ça quand
vous dites ils sont bien traités dans
les élevages bien sûr qu'ils sont bien
traités
sinon tu vas pas à voir arriver une mett
affaibli dans les cm1 traités parce
qu'ils sont là pour être tués c'est un
business à vous mettez une économie dans
le sud mais les mecs fait quelque chose
d'autre dans nos arènes invité des
chanteurs vous et on va sur la lune on
peut pas trouver une alternative au
corry d'aujourd'hui mais c'est leur
faudra tôt ou aider à qui on coupe les
oreilles et la cas clairement les
unanimement les français ya eu un débat
sur les animaux d'abattoir monsieur
parler des animaux d'abattoir tout à
l'heure ils disaient oui les animaux
d'abattoir machin des gens se plaint on
demande des caméras dans les abattoirs
pour contrôler si ya pas de cruauté
envers les animaux et à nîmes on est là
dans un abattoir à ciel ouvert avec des
mecs qui mangent du pop corn qui font la
ola devant un animal qui est en train de
se faire réduire en miettes clairement
non parce que non jamais en discuter
nous disais bon ça serait bien s'ils
avaient pas la mise à mort le problème
c'est qu'il ya la mise à mort de toute
façon le tour on pourra pas le réparer
parce qu'il est blessé à mort on le
bleis armée tout puisqu'à l'époque les
chorégraphié il meurt pas mais si on me
dit ce que je viens vous dire vous dites
il est déjà mort il ya d'ailleurs déjà
milité j'en ai visité quelques jours
après que le taux d'intégration de
béziers lors du colisée
j'étais dans l'es9 à la retraite ça se
passe comment il finit à la boucherie
une retraite de roi mais pas d'un
magnifique
les taureaux bon il ya une chose qui est
un fait qui est intéressante lancée à la
spa a accusé un des plus grands toreros
français sébastien castella sévices
graves ou actes de cruauté envers un
animal domestique ou captifs et accusé
la ville de béziers et le directeur des
arènes robert margé de complicité le
jugement qui a été rendu par le tribunal
de béziers
ils ont été évidemment relaxer mais il a
observé le tribunal que l'élevage
apparaît en réalité beaucoup plus
respectueux de l'animal tant dans le
rapport à l'homme que dans la nourriture
apporter les soins prodigués que pour la
plupart entre la plupart des animaux de
consommation humaine la dernière a été
déboutée et condamnée à payer 4500 euros
de frais de justice rivière il ya
benicio del toro qui est d'accord
will hunting vous dites que vous avez
commencé la corrida ya un an donc moi je
me pose la question qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans votre vie pour vous pour
commencer ça est ce qu'il a un souci de
masculinité quelque part pour été payés
combien non le lobby de halo reach et me
demande comment des gens moi je peux
vous le dire
la tauromachie à des avocats
extraordinaire les meilleurs avocats du
monde acquis caso jean cocteau monde est
sérieux monsieur pardon je sais de
francis cabrel est ce que ce sont bien
deux minutes il ya frank leboeuf qui
disent
[Applaudissements]
sans compter aujourd'hui elle est assez
violente pour qu'on veuille un minimum
de bienveillance un peu d'espoir et tout
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le public ne
souhaite plus des spectacles où on
torture tout simplement
mais bon je pense non je pense qu'en
2021 les gens ne veulent plus sain et à
nîmes pour vous dire il y à des écoles
de jeunes toreros ouvertement commencé à
6 ans si une caméra cachée par one voice
vous pouvez regarder images chercher des
tous sur internet et on voit partout
moment où les parents signent les
enfants ont l'obligation d'aller
régulièrement là bas de regarder et
ensuite de passer à l'acte comme un
jouet d'enfant baiser 10 ans vont à
l'annoncé des enfants ils en font des
épées grand comme ça dans des invectives
ont bel et bien demandé d'excusés vous
me dites ça comme si je le cachais
métier que je mange comme si je le
cachais large et c'est ce que vous dites
il ya amaury d'ailleurs leveaux qui je
ne marche pas du tout j'ai jamais été
pour le magazine causeur un dossier bien
combien vais-je et j'en ai écrit la
moitié puis on a on a réuni des gens
comme l'architecte rudy ricciotti le
chef étoilé pierre gagnaire et notion
vous avez défini excusez moi et je fais
fait deux pages sur le parcours d'un
jeune torero où on expliqué que les
écoles pour ims et pâques lâcher ben
quoi view
qu'est ce qui se passe alors je vais
vous parler du paquet 6 5 pi 5 1 ça va
très très loin qui décréta la paye
l'excommunication immédiate des
chrétiens qu'ils assisteraient aux
corridas c'était en 1567 vous me parlez
de l'archi du d'accord ben moi j'ai la
plus touchante donc d'accord c'était
excommunication pour ceux qui a assisté
à la corrida
or vous pouvez me citer les figures que
vous voulez l'art l'art c'est sans ses
rayons des choses plus belle et magique
aller
mettons qu'il vomisse des dizaines de
litres de ces procédés plus magique
monsieur que j'aime pour vendre votre
papier là vous êtes prêt à dire
n'importe quoi il parle et vous avez
essayé sans doute par le lobby de la
tauromachie vous même bien belle patine
donc soyez honnêtes ils vous ont donné
de l'argent vous légitimez sur un
plateau de télévision la torture animale
non mais c'est une ordure que je vous
accuse
vous savez la différence entre vous et
moi je sais que ces causes de
l'événement essayé moi ok c'est que moi
je je je crois que vous êtes sincère
d'accord je vous chrono crois que tu est
malhonnête dans les yeux il est illettré
l'heure où là c'est le répondre été
arrêté pourquoi il aurait payé loi on me
demande à ce que personne voter article
vous avez raté votre corps et vos à
vérone des badauds mais j'y mourrai pour
brassage après qui gère attendait le
rapport allégi j'aimerais pas les gars
dit vous savez gg je suis allé faire ce
voyage j'ai ma tante et sa elisabeth
lévy j'ai raconté ça il est bien entouré
et le oui s'ils étaient vos bd mémoire
la bride ajustable espagne étaient
partis en car à quoi la presse mais
j'aimerais terminer au lobby phénologie
venant mais vous me le demandez arrêté
une fois il est seulement dix
mondialistes
j'ai raconté ça elisabeth lévy qui m'a
dit écris moi un papier je lui ai écrit
un papier qu'elle a trouvé très bien
elle me dit je pense que tu devrais en
faire un deuxième
j'ai fait une interview de simon casas
elisabeth lévy a pris la décision d'en
faire un numéro spécial et la couverture
en sachant en sachant qu'on vendrait
moins parce que elle savait très bien
[Musique]
que c'est fatigant et des pâtes à mâcher
arrêté est en baisse c'est en baisse
dans tous les leaders in the rain sûr
mais c'est bien beau mais qu'ils
n'arrêtent pas de battre les records de
remplissage danser
c'est à 17 ans gars c'est mon cousin
avait organisée bah ouais c'est bien sûr
casas non mais si vous avez des chances
au nez c'est ça va quoi cette folie
on peut très bien faire des férias on
chante on danse on est ensemble et la
résine et marie laure asus ou pas tout
son adorable fiston peut très bien faire
des férias où on est tous ensemble ou on
s'amuse mais juste sans torture mais je
ne changerais on n'est pas allé loin le
meilleur ami les gens ne veulent pas
génial à prendre à des enfants de 6 ans
à torturer un vous et les sous marins
haute qualité vous ont dit oui déjà
lâché j'y allais pas de là des gens qui
disent si on arrête la tauromachie sinon
je te demande crise hier parce que les
lions qui dit alors il faut arrêter de
tout les trucs avec les animaux
non mais c'est pas pareil je n'ai encore
mais là on parle d'une mise à mort la
vaisselle à l'étude
diable est aux vaches moi c'est
l'abattoir à celles ouvertes c'est pas
du tout pareil lassé des autres on est
d'accord et grâce un débat une agonie
qui dure une vingtaine de minutes avec
un mec qui s'en met plein les fouilles
mais s'il ne les pyjamas à paillettes et
s'ils aiment les épais qu'il y fasse de
l'escrim voilà et on n'a plus les pros
il et laisse tranquille ça et tout va le
trot avec le matador du verbe matin
suivi en espagne la lumière et puisqu'on
parle de souffrance animale
je ne vais pas vous lire l'étude
maintenant non mais non mais excusez moi
y'a une étude très sérieuse a été fait
bras excusez moi juste pour les
téléspectateurs peuvent étudier au
regard des excuses à une étude très
sérieuse qui a été faite par le
directeur du département physiologie
animale de la falgalarié vétérinaire de
madrid
jérôme beaulieu madrid / excusez moi sur
la souffrance du taureau dans ses bras
et ses spas balmont c'est lui moi c'est
la conclusion oui
cette étude a bravo jaubert des
suppléments dvd
sessegnon cette étude révèle souris je
suis content de vous avoir vous et pas
seulement gallois mais vous êtes quand
même fatigante 1 on embrasse solveig
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui veut dire il
constate dans cette étude pratiqués sur
120 novillo donc des jeunes taureaux et
180 euros donc piqué et banderilles et
l'étude révèle à la faculté
il faut 10 mois sont d'une
exceptionnelle agressivité chez 7,3 du
toro brave presque unique dans le règne
animal un développement singulier de la
glande surrénale qui diffuse
l'adrénaline dans le sens acquis mais
qui va mourir c'est normal mais laissez
nous rire n'est pas tout seul tôt vers
des sons et smashes jamais rejoué
terminé c'est juste une phrase est la
conclusion de son étude c'est lors de la
pique
tu commences la corrida lors de la pique
le manioc donc connaître une douleur de
quelques millièmes de seconde
aussitôt bloqué par la libération d'un
flot de béton j'ai battu les éditions
c'est honteux de dire ça mais le sens
d'aider des millions de souffrance
horrible que vous légitimez l'avouent
légitimer la torture la brutalité la
mort d'un taureau monsieur en quelques
fractions de seconde c'est horrible ce
que vous dites très franchement sert il
a du mérite de vous laisser par les
frères ce que vous êtes en train de dire
vous êtes en train de dire oui on peut
tuer un animal c'est surtout très très
con honteux je dis respect a aucune mois
vous allez la wii ah oui tu manges pas
bien très bien la balle aux îles
pardonnez moi mais c'est extrêmement
content que vous venez de dire oui
pardon parce que bien évidemment que
c'était une des sacs est ce qu'elle veut
dire notre la grille en est un qui les
vivriers les niveaux il est mort non non
on arrête de tuer les animaux
il est bloqué au stade a menacé gbagbo
si vous n'en démordez pas c'est quand
même c'est vrai comme un hymne que
j'étais désolé je soupçonne des dvd
temps ça existe on tue pas le taureau
très intéressant l'étude révèle que le
taureau souffre beaucoup plus de stress
dans les autres formes de toros match
donc c'est ici ah bah oui diplômes sont
en règle dont il va tomber secteur de
sars et c'est pas parce qu'on a un mini
avoir jeté respect c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'on pense des spectateurs ce pee wee
[Applaudissements]
et l'on abatte 9% merci à yanis et ziadi
et merci à crise fière d'avoir été avec
nous c'était animé mais je peux juste
rajouter je soupçonne certains certes un
aficionado d'attendre que le toréador se
fasse en corner pour kiffer parce que
franchement il faut en parler aussi de
la personne en face si vous voulez faire
des vrais combats avec un vrai
adversaire remonté sur un ring de boxe
le vrai courage c'est tout les mecs qui
se lève tous les matins pour nourrir
leur famille ça c'est le koura corses
avaient encore déployé des dizaines de
milliers de roms comme ça parce que
n'at-on pas de la lopé ce n'est pas je
demande juste aux gens qui ont un avis
sur la corrida évidemment sans la
connaître de s'y intéresser avant
d'avoir un avis et honnêtement on a fait
un dossier très excusez moi allez
regarder où on avance on a fait un
dossier allait regarder les autres frais
qui vient nous a pas avec ça
[Applaudissements]
ici on parle pas comme ça des toros qui
respecte les camps et un lectorat gilles
respecter les arbitres mais qui respecte
leur au temps des fêtes c'est vrai non
merci je m'excuse du comportement
peut-être discourtois mais franchement
arrêtez d'écrire de la reine mère mais
jéloux voit l'énergie orangis pas servir
dont je comprends je suis en fait cette
propagande vous dites que les arènes
sont pleines ici les téléspectateurs de
tpm mais quand on fait un sourire a
généralement c'est un peu le panel des
français puisque tout le monde regarde
l'émission et gamme 75% que la brise qui
sont contre alors moi alors mais vous
êtes déjà à l'intérieur des arènes les
théâtres sont à moitié vit le problème
c'est que dans 1 d'argent et verton
entre une conversion parce que vous
comme vous êtes comédiens vous
remplissez pas les pages sur la
tauromachie de toreros qu'on joue cet
été au festival nava de place à gilles
verdez rémois avec plus non mais moi
honnêtement avec plaisir moi je moi j'ai
envie de moi je suis je suis pour la
discussion
je comprends qu'on n'aime pas la corrida
rich pageant et yannick et je peux
comprendre le noir le lendemain son
décès
son avis avant de m'y intéresser ça me
dégoûte est la corrida et je me suis
intéressé j'ai changé j'ai envie de
danser avec les gens avec plaisir de la
conduite en personne dans les arènes
aujourd'hui c'est vous vos parents vous
savez que je suis et je suis né en
région parisienne d'un père tunisien et
d'une mère française de seine et marne
je n'ai rien à voir avec la corrida je
sais ça m'a passionné
ça m'a fait grandir ça m'a rendu
meilleur je le dis parce que ça m'a
sensibilisé sort des animaux que vous le
vouliez ou non personne j'ai d'ailleurs
mené aux journalistes en tout cas c'est
ce que je vois là non c'est parce que
d'isabelle elle a trouvé le papier je
conteste le dossier mais il est très
bien flers isabelle merci je sais pas
lire
vous avez reçu votre petit fils a dit
des fonctionnaires